everywhere she goes it seems there is
one song that follows
[Music]
the whole nation's hero
but of course there's no one prouder
than mum the Kelly family now all back
home in hanwell West London just 10
miles from Wembley to continue the
celebrations
scored I thought I'm proud of my third
parents be because we were all so proud
and then when Chloe scored I was oh I
was ecstatic I cried it was just oh my I
can't I just can't put it into words
it was here that it All Began for
England's match winner but she didn't
have your typical football upbringing
the estate's local pitch was in a cage
and back then the surface was gravel
it's on this very pitch that Chloe Kelly
learned to play football from the age of
seven with her five older brothers and
their mates and it's that experience
that she says made her the player she is
today teaching her creativity
physicality and the skills to get out of
tight spaces
she used to come in she had cuts on her
knees she was always bounced off of the
cage floors and I used to say to her
well don't go then and she'd still go
back the next day and she'd yeah did you
mind her no I didn't no I didn't care
because she I know she was tough as old
boots her first Club was QPR after being
spotted at a school tournament
Julie Curley was her PE teacher and says
she always knew Chloe would do something
special I remember her first day so
clearly
um I walked through the playground and I
could see this young blonde girl doing
keep yuppies in the playground and a
large group of people gathered around
her and I thought wow like this this
girl has skills who is she and little
did I realize how just quite how
skillful she was despite those skills it
was touch and go as to whether she'd
even be at the Euros after a
career-threatening knee injury last year
put her out of action until April but
this is someone who doesn't give up
she's just really really humble she's
hard working she's really coachable
which is great and like I say when she
she goes onto the pitch she's just like
us you know she's got the street fighter
determination and now it's not just her
goal people are talking about
her celebration
there really is only one Chloe Kelly and
she and she's not going to let this
moment pass her back
Bennett Sky News in hanwell West London